Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At approximately 7.30am on Wednesday July 18, 2018, Mobile Alabama resident Julie Dykes-Thomas received a phone call from an unfamiliar number. A man on the other line said he had found a mobile phone that contained photos of a baby and he assumed the owner would want it back.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。关于保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上本期节目的简介。2018年7月18日星期三上午7点30分左右，阿拉巴马州莫比尔市居民朱莉·戴克斯-托马斯（Julie Dykes-Thomas）接到一个陌生号码打来的电话。电话那头的一名男子说，他找到了一部手机，里面有婴儿的照片，他猜失主会想要拿回手机。
Julie soon established that the phone in question belonged to her son's 25-year-old girlfriend, Daniela Vayan. Julie thanked the man and asked if he could drop the phone off at Daniela's workplace, the Asian-themed restaurant chain PF Changs in Mobile's Bel Air Mall. Julie wasn't alarmed by the call. Daniela had purchased a new car the day prior and Julie thought she must have gone out to celebrate and had lost her phone at some point during the evening. This wasn't unusual for Daniela as she had lost other phones in the past.
朱莉很快确认，这部手机属于她儿子25岁的女朋友丹妮拉·瓦扬（Daniela Vayan）。朱莉向该男子道谢，并询问他是否可以将手机送到丹妮拉的工作地点——位于莫比尔贝尔空气购物中心（Bel Air Mall）的亚洲主题连锁餐厅P.F. Chang's。朱莉并没有对这通电话感到惊慌。丹妮拉前一天刚买了一辆新车，朱莉认为她一定是出去庆祝了，并在当晚的某个时候弄丢了手机。这对于丹妮拉来说并不罕见，因为她过去也弄丢过其他手机。
Julie assumed it would only be a matter of time before Daniela showed up and would be relieved to know her phone had been found. At 9am, Julie called the building manager of Daniela's apartment complex and asked them to have Daniela return her call. The building manager said that Daniela wasn't at home, so Julie asked that they leave a note on her door saying that Julie knew who had her phone. Later that day, the founder of Daniela's phone called Julie again, this time offering to meet her in person to hand it over.
朱莉以为丹妮拉出现只是时间问题，而且她知道手机被找到后一定会松一口气。上午9点，朱莉打电话给丹妮拉公寓大楼的物业经理，请他们让丹妮拉给她回电话。物业经理说丹妮拉不在家，于是朱莉请他们在她的门上留个便条，说明朱莉知道谁拿着她的手机。那天晚些时候，找到丹妮拉手机的人再次给朱莉打电话，这次提出要亲自见她把手机交还。
Julie repeated her request that he drop it at PF Changs, where the staff would keep it safe until Daniela arrived for her next shift. By 4pm, Julie still hadn't heard from Daniela. She went over to her apartment, only to find the note the building manager had pinned to the front door was still there. Daniela wasn't at home, further supporting Julie's theory that she must be recovering from the night before at a friend's house. Julie was certain she would either call at some point as she knew Julie's phone number
朱莉再次请求他把手机送到P.F. Chang's，那里的员工会代为保管，直到丹妮拉来上下一个班。到了下午4点，朱莉仍然没有听到丹妮拉的消息。她走到丹妮拉的公寓，却发现物业经理贴在前门上的便条依然原封不动地贴在那里。丹妮拉不在家，这更加印证了朱莉的推测：她一定是在某个朋友家度过宿醉后的恢复期。朱莉确信她要么会在某个时候打电话来，因为她能
by heart, or would turn up the following day. Daniela's 4-year-old daughter Cora had been visiting relatives for the past week and Julie knew that there was no way Daniela would miss her little girl's homecoming. The next morning of Thursday, July 19, the man who found Daniela's phone called again. Julie was growing irritated and a little confused as to why he kept calling her instead of dropping the phone at Daniela's work like she'd requested. As he seemed reluctant to do so, Julie told him to hold onto the phone and she would let him know as soon as Daniela got in touch.
熟记朱莉的电话号码，要么第二天就会露面。丹妮拉4岁的女儿科拉（Cora）过去一周一直在探亲，朱莉知道丹妮拉绝不可能错过女儿回家。第二天，即7月19日星期四上午，找到丹妮拉手机的那名男子又打来电话。朱莉开始感到恼火，而且有点不解，为什么他一直打电话给她，而不是像她要求的那样把手机送到丹妮拉的工作单位。既然他似乎不愿这么做，朱莉便告诉他先保管好手机，等丹妮拉一联系她，她就会通知他。
The man asked if they should be concerned, to which Julie assured him that there was nothing to worry about. It struck Julie as odd that this stranger was showing so much concern. Daniela Nicole Vian was born in Roswell, New Mexico on March 8, 1993, to mother Joy and a biological father she never knew. When she was very young, her stepfather, Bill Vian, legally adopted her and she took on his surname. Bill was in the military and the family moved around often.
那名男子问他们是否应该担心，朱莉则向他保证没什么好担心的。朱莉觉得奇怪的是，这个陌生人竟然表现出这么多的关心。丹妮拉·妮可·维安（Daniela Nicole Vian）于1993年3月8日出生于新墨西哥州罗斯韦尔，母亲是乔伊（Joy），生父不详。她很小的时候，继父比尔·维安（Bill Vian）依法收养了她，她便随了他的姓。比尔是一名军人，一家人经常搬迁。
Growing up, Daniela had a reasonable rapport with her stepfather, but her relationship with her mother was reportedly tumultuous. As a result, Daniela spent much of her adolescence cow-chopping and staying with friends while the Vians were stationed at the Fort Riley military base in North Central Kansas. Daniela later adopted the Instagram username, at, former street kid, in reference to her 13-age years, although it's unclear whether she was kicked out of home or was transient by choice. Fort Riley is one of the largest and oldest military installations in the United States
在成长过程中，丹妮拉与继父的关系还算融洽，但据报道她与母亲的关系却十分动荡。因此，当维安一家驻扎在中北堪萨斯州的赖利堡（Fort Riley）军事基地时，丹妮拉的大部分青春期都是在四处游荡和借宿朋友家度过的。丹妮拉后来将自己的Instagram用户名改为“前街头儿童”（at, former street kid），以此指代她13岁时的生活，不过目前尚不清楚她是被赶出家门还是自愿流浪。赖利堡是美国最大、最古老的军事设施之一，
and is home to many families of servicemen and women. It was there that Daniela met Julie's son, Tyler Sean Thomas, who was a couple of years her senior. The two had a lot in common. Both had grown up in America's Bible Belt region in military families who believed in God, guns and patriotism. Their military upbringings had required them to move from base to base, which meant constant disruptions and a loss of friendship ties.
这里居住着许多军人家庭。正是在那里，丹妮拉遇到了朱莉的儿子泰勒·肖恩·托马斯（Tyler Sean Thomas），他比丹妮拉大几岁。两人有很多共同点。他们都在美国的“圣经带”地区长大，成长于崇尚上帝、枪支和爱国主义的军人家庭。他们的军人家庭背景要求他们不断在各个基地之间搬迁，这意味着不断的颠沛流离和友谊纽带的丢失。
As such, they had both developed a necessary resilience and ability to adapt. Like Daniela, Tyler never knew his biological father and had been adopted by his stepfather, Patrick Tyler, as a baby. Although the military subculture brought them together, there was no immediate romantic connection between Tyler and Daniela. When Tyler was 18, he married another girl, but it didn't last long. Soon after, Tyler followed his stepfather's footsteps and signed up for the military, taking on a communications role.
因此，两人都培养出了必要的韧性和适应能力。和丹妮拉一样，泰勒从未见过自己的生父，在还是婴儿时就被继父帕特里克·泰勒（Patrick Tyler）收养。尽管军事亚文化将他们聚在了一起，但泰勒和丹妮拉之间并没有立刻产生浪漫的恋情。泰勒18岁时娶了另一个女孩，但这段婚姻并没有持续多久。不久之后，泰勒步了继父的后尘应征入伍，担任通信兵。
He was deployed to both Iraq and Afghanistan, where he used social media to keep in touch with his old circle of friends, particularly Daniela. The two found they had other things in common besides military life, such as an interest in tattoos, and were both artistically talented. When Tyler returned to the United States, he hastily greeted his parents at their home in Mobile, Alabama, before making the three-hour trip to visit 18-year-old Daniela. Their rekindled friendship quickly grew into a relationship, and they officially started dating.
他被派往伊拉克和阿富汗，在那里他利用社交媒体与老朋友保持联系，尤其是丹妮拉。两人发现除了军旅生活之外，他们还有其他共同点，比如都对纹身感兴趣，并且都很有艺术天赋。泰勒回到美国后，匆忙赶往阿拉巴马州莫比尔市的家中看望父母，然后便驱车三个小时去探望18岁的丹妮拉。他们重燃的友谊迅速发展成恋爱关系，并正式开始交往。
Tyler returned to the military, where he spent six months before being discharged. As soon as he was finished, he asked Daniela to move with him to Mobile. Mobile is part of America's Bible Belt, an informal region in the country's southeast that encompasses more than a dozen states with a conservative culture. The overall crime rate is 126% higher than the national average, with violent crimes such as rape, homicide, and aggravated assault trending upwards over the past 10 years. It has close to the highest crime rate of anywhere in Alabama, and almost double the national average murder rate.
泰勒重返部队，服役六个月后退伍。他一退伍就要求丹妮拉跟他一起搬到莫比尔。莫比尔是美国“圣经带”的一部分，“圣经带”是该国东南部的一个非正式区域，包含十多个具有保守文化的州。这里的整体犯罪率比全国平均水平高出126%，强奸、凶杀和严重攻击等暴力犯罪在过去10年中呈上升趋势。它的犯罪率在阿拉巴马州几乎名列前茅，谋杀率几乎是全国平均水平的两倍。
In Mobile, individuals have a one in 17 chance of becoming a victim of any crime, and a one in 132 chance of becoming a victim of a violent crime. Mobile has a history of economic swings, with much of its income derived from a robust domestic and international shipping industry through the Mobile ports. The western neighborhoods where Tyler Thomas' family lived were characterized by pawn shops, payday loans, dollar stores, fast food chains, and billboards advertising no win, no fee personal injury lawyers. The most popular activities in the area, besides hunting, all typically involved water, with
在莫比尔，个人成为任何犯罪受害者的几率为十七分之一，成为暴力犯罪受害者的几率为一百三十二分之一。莫比尔有着经济起伏的历史，其大部分收入来自通过莫比尔港口蓬勃发展的国内和国际航运业。泰勒·托马斯一家居住的西部社区的特点是当铺、发薪日贷款、一元店、快餐连锁店以及宣传无胜诉不收费个人伤害律师的广告牌。除了打猎之外，该地区最受欢迎的活动通常都与水有关，
residents taking advantage of Mobile Bay, the Mobile River Delta, and the nearby Gulf of Mexico to take part in sailing, fishing, kayaking, swimming, diving, or just hanging out on the beach. Daniela Vaillan didn't hesitate to move to Mobile with Tyler, but as the couple had no money, they moved in with Tyler's parents, Julie and Patrick, and his brother PJ. From that moment on, Daniela only had sporadic contact with her own family, preferring to blend in with the Thomas family instead. From the outset, Tyler and Daniela's relationship was rocky.
居民们利用莫比尔湾、莫比尔河三角洲以及附近的墨西哥湾进行帆船、钓鱼、皮划艇、游泳、潜水，或者只是在海滩上闲逛。丹妮拉·瓦扬毫不犹豫地和泰勒一起搬到了莫比尔，但由于两人身无分文，他们住进了泰勒的父母朱莉和帕特里克以及他的兄弟PJ家里。从那一刻起，丹妮拉与自己家人的联系变得零星，宁愿融入托马斯一家。从一开始，泰勒和丹妮拉的关系就波折不断。
Tyler hadn't been the same since leaving the military. He suffered from post-traumatic stress disorder and didn't respond well to conventional treatment. Instead, he self-medicated with drugs, which culminated in a heroin habit. Tyler was no stranger to the police and was arrested for various felony and misdemeanor offenses. Yet, Daniela and Tyler loved each other. They both designed tattoos, and over time Daniela required several, including a mandala style flower on her left shoulder, a gray outline of an elephant on her right wrist,
泰勒离开军队后就判若两人。他患有创伤后应激障碍，对传统治疗反应不佳。相反，他通过药物进行自我治疗，最终导致了海洛因成瘾。泰勒对警察并不陌生，曾因各种重罪和轻罪被捕。然而，丹妮拉和泰勒深爱着彼此。他们都设计纹身，随着时间推移，丹妮拉身上有了几个纹身，包括左肩上的一朵曼陀罗风格的花、右腕上大象的灰色轮廓，
an outline of a heart, a Buddha, and an American flag with a unicorn where the stars should be on her inside right thigh. On her left collarbone, she had a matching tattoo to Tyler, which was the image of two graveyard headstones sitting side by side. Inside the tombstones were the words, to die by your side. In early 2013, Daniela and Tyler discovered that they were going to be parents. Determined to provide a good life for their newborn, they got their own apartment in Mobile and prepared to become a family.
一颗心形轮廓、一尊佛像，以及右大腿内侧本该是星星的地方却画着独角兽的美国国旗。在她的左锁骨上，她有一个与泰勒相匹配的纹身，那是两块并排而立的墓碑的图像。墓碑里面刻着这样一句话：“死在你的身旁”。2013年初，丹妮拉和泰勒发现他们即将为人父母。为了给新生儿提供美好的生活，他们在莫比尔租了一套属于自己的公寓，并为组成家庭做好了准备。
Their daughter, Cora, was born in late 2013, but for the first month, she was placed into the custody of her grandparents, Julie and Patrick. Daniela and Tyler tried to make things work, but it soon became evident that their own house wasn't a healthy environment in which to raise their daughter. Although Daniela yearned to be a good mother, she felt the only way to do so was to let Cora stay at Tyler's parents' house most of the time. Tyler's heroin addiction continued to be a major issue, resulting in several arrests and stints in rehab.
他们的女儿科拉于2013年底出生，但在第一个月里，她被交由祖父母朱莉和帕特里克抚养。丹妮拉和泰勒试图让生活步入正轨，但很快人们就发现，他们自己的住所并不是一个抚养女儿的健康环境。尽管丹妮拉渴望成为一个好母亲，但她觉得这样做的唯一方法就是让科拉大部分时间都住在泰勒父母家里。泰勒的海洛因成瘾继续成为一个重大问题，导致他多次被捕并在戒毒所进进出出。
The couple fought constantly, accusing one another of infidelity, and their arguments sometimes turned into physical altercations. Daniela bounced around a number of different jobs in restaurants and bars around Mobile. She made friends easily enough, but due to her busy work schedule, her friends tended to be workmates. In order to sustain herself through double shifts, she sometimes turned to Vivant, a prescription amphetamine used to treat ADHD, similar to the better-known Adderall. As well as increasing alertness and decreasing appetite, Vivant's can cause the user to
这对夫妇经常吵架，互相指责对方不忠，他们的争吵有时会演变成肢体冲突。丹妮拉在莫比尔各地的餐馆和酒吧换了许多不同的工作。她很容易结交朋友，但由于工作日程繁忙，她的朋友往往都是同事。为了支撑自己完成双班倒的工作，她有时会求助于Vivant——一种用于治疗多动症的处方苯丙胺类药物，类似于人们更熟悉的阿德拉（Adderall）。Vivant除了能提高警觉性和降低食欲外，还会导致使用者
become jittery and anxious. It is tightly controlled, as it can easily be abused and cause dependence. Daniela didn't have a prescription, but sourced the drug via other methods. On March 25, 2015, during one of the many rough patches in the couple's relationship, Tyler filed a petition against Daniela for custody of Cora. In it, he wrote, I have been the sole provider for Cora since she was born. I am the only parent with a driver's license and the only parent with a steady work history.
变得神经质和焦虑。由于它很容易被滥用并导致依赖性，因此受到严格管控。丹妮拉没有处方，而是通过其他途径购买这种药物。2015年3月25日，在两人关系中的众多艰难时期之一，泰勒向法院提交了一份关于科拉抚养权的申请。他在其中写道：“自科拉出生以来，我一直是她的唯一抚养人。我是唯一拥有驾照的家长，也是唯一有稳定工作经历的家长。
I have gathered evidence of Daniela using drugs around Cora and evidence of her being unfit as a mother. I have been doing everything in my power to have contact with my daughter, and it has been denied. I do not plan on keeping Cora from her mother. I simply need a way back into my daughter's life. When the case came up in Family Court in October, Tyler failed to appear, and the judge dismissed the application.
我已经收集了丹妮拉在科拉周围吸毒的证据，以及她不适合当母亲的证据。我一直在尽我所能与女儿取得联系，但遭到拒绝。我不打算把科拉从她母亲身边带走。我只是需要一条重新回到我女儿生活中的途径。”当这起案件于10月在家庭法院开庭审理时，泰勒未能出庭，法官驳回了该申请。
By this point, Cora was living with Julian Patrick, who started to discuss taking on full custody. Although Daniela missed having Cora with her all the time, she knew the stability that Julian Patrick could provide was in Cora's best interests. Tyler's heroin addiction continued to worsen, and in early 2016, he went to jail for breaking and entering. During his incarceration, Daniela started dating other people, but she and Tyler reunited after his release.
此时，科拉和朱莉、帕特里克住在一起，他们开始讨论争取完全抚养权。尽管丹妮拉很怀念科拉一直陪在身边的日子，但她知道朱莉和帕特里克能够提供的稳定性最符合科拉的利益。泰勒的海洛因瘾进一步恶化，2016年初，他因入室盗窃而入狱。在他服刑期间，丹妮拉开始和别人约会，但在他出狱后，她和泰勒又复合了。
At the toxic nature of their relationship, she told her concerned friends that Tyler wasn't just her boyfriend and the father of her child, but had also been her best friend for seven years. He continued to spend time in and out of jail, living with Daniela in their apartment whenever he was released, even when they weren't romantically involved. Towards the end of 2017, Tyler was serving time for failing a drug test that was a condition of his probation. He was then moved into rehab, where he was allowed to spend one day a week out with Daniela.
鉴于他们关系的恶劣本质，她对担心的朋友说，泰勒不仅是她的男朋友和孩子的父亲，也是她七年来的挚友。他继续在监狱里进进出出，只要一获释就和丹妮拉住在他们的公寓里，哪怕他们当时并没有恋爱关系。2017年底，泰勒因未能通过作为缓刑条件的药物测试而正在服刑。随后他被转入戒毒所，在那里他被允许每周有一天时间外出与丹妮拉相聚。
Upon his release, Daniela announced that she was pregnant. Tyler was overjoyed and vowed to stay clean. After they visited the doctor and established the time of conception, however, it became clear that Tyler couldn't be the father. Nevertheless, he told Daniela he would support her throughout the pregnancy until she gave the child up for adoption. By December, Daniela had started to show, and Tyler lashed out in anger and humiliation at being faced with proof of her infidelity.
出狱后，丹妮拉宣布自己怀孕了。泰勒欣喜若狂，并誓言要保持清洁。然而，在他们去看医生并确定了受孕时间后，情况变得明朗起来：泰勒不可能是孩子的父亲。尽管如此，他还是告诉丹妮拉，他会在整个孕期支持她，直到她把孩子送去收养。到了12月，丹妮拉开始显怀，泰勒面对她出轨的证据，愤怒和羞辱交加，大发雷霆。
The situation became untenable for Daniela, and she decided to try and reconnect with her mother, Joy, who was living in North Carolina. Daniela wanted to go back to college and work toward some sort of future for herself, Cora, and perhaps the new baby. She also wanted to get away from Mobile and put some distance between herself and Tyler. Cora stayed behind with Julian Patrick while Daniela traveled to North Carolina. But the move was short-lived. Daniela missed Cora and Tyler, so she soon returned to Mobile.
这种情况对丹妮拉来说变得难以承受，她决定尝试与住在北卡罗来纳州的母亲乔伊重新建立联系。丹妮拉想重返大学，为自己、科拉、或许还有新出生的孩子争取某种未来。她还想离开莫比尔，与泰勒保持一定距离。丹妮拉前往北卡罗来纳州时，科拉留在了朱莉和帕特里克身边。但这次搬迁很短暂。丹妮拉思念科拉和泰勒，于是很快又回到了莫比尔。
Upon her return, Daniela started working at PF Changs, where one of her fellow servers, Hannah Jakobowski, took her under her wing. When Daniela told her she didn't have a car because Tyler had wrecked it some time earlier, Hannah offered her a ride home, and the two were delighted to discover they lived just minutes away from one another. They struck up a friendship, and from then on, Hannah gave Daniela a lift to and from PF Changs nearly every shift, even if Hannah herself wasn't working. The two women were similar in many ways, and when Hannah started attending cosmetology
回来后，丹妮拉开始在P.F. Chang's工作，在那里，她的同事之一汉娜·雅各布斯基（Hannah Jakobowski）对她多加照顾。当丹妮拉告诉她自己没有车，因为泰勒不久前把车撞毁了时，汉娜主动提出开车送她回家，两人高兴地发现她们的住处相距只有几分钟路程。她们就此结下友谊，从那以后，几乎每一次换班汉娜都会顺便载丹妮拉去P.F. Chang's上班并送她回家，哪怕汉娜自己并没有排班。两个女人在很多方面都很相似，当汉娜开始上美容
school, Daniela was only too happy to help out. She let Hannah try out hair colors and styles on her as she enjoyed changing her style often. At various times, Daniela had blonde, brown, red, blue, green, and even multicolored hair. Daniela worked almost every single day and often pulled double shifts in a bid to save money. She needed enough to fund her upcoming maternity leave and also hoped to buy a car, which would give her freedom and the ability to see Cora whenever she wanted. The father of Daniela's unborn baby had no interest in raising his child, but offered
学校时，丹妮拉非常乐意帮忙。她让汉娜在自己头上尝试不同的发色和造型，因为她喜欢经常改变自己的风格。在不同的时期，丹妮拉染过金色、棕色、红色、蓝色、绿色甚至是多色相间的头发。为了攒钱，丹妮拉几乎每天都上班，并且经常连上两个班。她需要足够的资金来应对即将到来的产假，同时也希望能买一辆车，这样她就能获得自由，并能随时去看望科拉。丹妮拉未出生孩子的父亲对抚养孩子没有兴趣，但提出如果她想自己抚养孩子，他会提供
financial support if she wanted to bring the child up herself. Daniela decided to proceed with an open adoption, which meant she was able to meet potential adoptive parents. After screening through applications, Daniela decided on a married couple from Mobile, a teacher, and a police officer. On June 6, 2018, Daniela gave birth to a baby boy. The adoptive parents joined her during the birth, and she let them cut the umbilical cord, hoping it would help form an immediate bond for the new family.
经济支持。丹妮拉决定进行开放式收养，这意味着她可以与潜在的收养父母见面。经过对申请的筛选，丹妮拉选中了莫比尔的一对已婚夫妇，其中一人是教师，另一人是警察。2018年6月6日，丹妮拉生下一个男婴。收养父母在她分娩期间一直陪伴在她身旁，她让他们剪了脐带，希望这能帮助这个新家庭迅速建立起纽带。
The adoptive parents were willing for the child to know who Daniela was, but she didn't think that was a good idea. Through Alabama law, the birth mother can change her mind for up to five days after the adoption, but Daniela and her son's adoptive parents established an agreement that she would have up to six months. On the day of the birth, Tyler overdosed on heroin in his car, but an ambulance resuscitated him with Narcan, which immediately negated the effects of the drug. Tyler proceeded to the hospital as though nothing had happened, and was there to support
收养父母愿意让孩子知道丹妮拉是谁，但她觉得这不是个好主意。根据阿拉巴马州的法律，亲生母亲在收养后的五天内可以改变主意，但丹妮拉和她儿子的收养父母达成了一项协议，即她可以有长达六个月的考虑期。在分娩当天，泰勒在车内因海洛因过量而昏迷，但救护车用纳洛酮（Narcan）将他救活，这种药物能立即消除该药物的影响。泰勒像没事人一样前往医院，并在那里陪伴
Daniela through the birth of her little boy. Afterwards, he turned himself in to be put back in jail for once again violating the conditions of his parole. On the evening of the birth, Daniela sent a text message to Julie to say she was sore but okay and that she hadn't yet seen her baby and wasn't sure if she wanted to. She wrote a letter for her son, which she gave to his adoptive parents to give to him on his 18th birthday. She then left the hospital without holding her baby boy.
丹妮拉度过了小男孩出生的时刻。随后，他自首入狱，因为他再次违反了假释条件。在分娩当晚，丹妮拉给朱莉发了一条短信，说她身体酸痛但一切都好，她还没见过自己的孩子，也不确定自己是否想见。她为儿子写了一封信，交给了他的收养父母，以便在他18岁生日时交给他。随后，她甚至没有抱抱那个小男孩就离开了医院。
Despite reassuring Julie that she was in good health, Daniela had experienced complications during labor that continued after she left the hospital. She was in a great deal of pain and was bleeding heavily, but three days after the birth, Daniela returned to work. Determined to save money, she pushed herself hard and didn't give herself time to heal. Instead, she relied on Norco, a strong prescription painkiller similar to the better known Vicodin, which can cause drowsiness. Users are warned never to mix Norco with alcohol.
尽管向朱莉保证自己身体健康，但丹妮拉在分娩期间确实经历了并发症，这些并发症在她离开医院后仍在持续。她疼痛难忍，出血严重，但在分娩三天后，丹妮拉就重返工作岗位。为了攒钱，她对自己要求很高，没有给自己留出时间养伤。相反，她依靠Norco——一种强效处方止痛药，类似于人们更熟悉的维柯丁（Vicodin），这种药物会导致困倦。使用者被警告切勿将Norco与酒精混用。
With the birth and adoption complete and Tyler back in jail, Daniela seemed more motivated than ever to work toward a better life for herself and Cora. Her main priority was buying a car, as she didn't like being reliant on friends and Tyler's family to drive her around. On June 17, less than two weeks after giving birth, Daniela wrote a list of goals in her journal using fancy writing and illustrating the page with tattoo-style pictures. She had successfully saved up enough money to place a down payment on a car and was taking the necessary steps to secure the one she wanted.
随着分娩和收养的完成以及泰勒重回监狱，丹妮拉比以往任何时候都更有动力为自己和科拉争取更美好的生活。她的首要任务是买一辆车，因为她不喜欢依赖朋友和泰勒的家人开车送她四处奔波。6月17日，即产后不到两周，丹妮拉用花体字在日记里写下了一份目标清单，并用纹身风格的图片装饰了这一页。她已经成功攒够了买车的首付款，并正在采取必要步骤来确保买到她心仪的车。
Her dreams and goals for what came next related mostly to Cora. Daniela wrote that she wanted to get Cora's bedroom together, take her to school every day, get her involved with a sport or dance, and have Cora sleep over 80% of the time. The other goals related to getting her finances under control by paying down her bank overdraft and credit card. She also wanted to start school and focus on being more positive. At the top of the page, Daniela wrote, We need to see what the world could be, not what it is.
她对未来的梦想和目标主要与科拉有关。丹妮拉写道，她想把科拉的卧室收拾好，每天送她上学，让她参与一项运动或舞蹈，并让科拉80%的时间都跟她一起过夜。其他目标则与通过偿还银行透支和信用卡来控制财务有关。她还想开始上学，专注于变得更积极向上。在页面顶端，丹妮拉写道：“我们看到的世界应当是它可能成为的样子，而不是它现在的样子。”
On Monday, July 16, 2018, Daniela went to the Pearl Motors car dealership to purchase a dark blue 2014 Chevrolet Cruze. Pearl Motors was a buy here pay here dealership, which meant it specialized in older used cars with high mileage for clients with a bad credit history. Buy here pay here dealers often provide on-site financing options for those who are unable to get credit elsewhere, offering loans with higher interest rates. The loan comes directly from the dealer, who will often stipulate that the repayments have to be made in person in cash.
2018年7月16日星期一，丹妮拉前往珍珠汽车行（Pearl Motors）购买了一辆深蓝色2014款雪佛兰科鲁兹（Chevrolet Cruze）。珍珠汽车行是一家“买即付”（buy here pay here）车行，这意味着它专门为信用记录不佳的客户提供行驶里程高的高龄二手车。“买即付”车行通常为无法在别处获得信贷的人提供现场融资选择，提供利率更高的贷款。贷款直接来自车行，车行通常会规定必须当面以现金偿还。
The car Daniela wanted was worth around $10,000, which required a down payment of $1,500. Pearl Motors agreed to let her pay $1,000 of the down payment in cash, with the remaining $500 to be paid by the end of the month. However, she had to pay for her insurance via a bank transfer, which was a problem, as Daniela's bank account was overdrawn. She didn't have enough money to pay the full amount owed to her overdrawn account as well as her insurance, so she decided to deposit the cash into Julie's account, from which the insurance would then be paid.
丹妮拉想要的车价值约10,000美元，需要支付1,500美元的首付款。珍珠汽车行同意让她以现金支付1,000美元首付款，剩余的500美元在月底前付清。然而，她必须通过银行转账支付保险费，这成了一个问题，因为丹妮拉的银行账户透支了。她没有足够的钱既付清透支账户的欠款又支付保险，因此她决定将现金存入朱莉的账户，然后从该账户支付保险费。
Pearl Motors required a number of documents from Daniela, including a letter of recommendation from her landlord stating she was reliable in paying her rent. She borrowed Julie's car and spent the day going back and forth getting all of the paperwork together so that she could pick up the car the next day. When she finally got everything sorted, she returned the car to Julie's house in the afternoon. It was just six weeks since she had given birth and she was exhausted and still in pain. Daniela lay down on the couch and took her painkillers. She was staying at Julie's that night.
珍珠汽车行需要丹妮拉提供多项文件，包括房东的推荐信，证明她付房租很可靠。她借了朱莉的车，花了一整天时间来回奔波，把所有的纸质文件凑齐，以便第二天把车提走。当她终于把一切都办妥后，便在下午把车还到了朱莉家。此时距离她生孩子才过去六周，她精疲力竭，依然浑身疼痛。丹妮拉躺在沙发上，吃了止痛药。那天晚上她住在朱莉家。
Julie's husband Patrick, son PJ, and little Cora were away visiting Patrick's sister in Selma about a three-hour drive north. They had been away for almost a week and were due back in Mobile on Thursday, July 19. Julie and Daniela discussed their upcoming plans. The following day, Julie intended to drive Daniela to the bank and then to Pearl Motors to pick up her car. Once Daniela had the car, she wanted to go shopping for some school supplies for Cora, including a tie-dyed backpack the little girl had previously admired.
朱莉的丈夫帕特里克、儿子PJ和小科拉正在向北开车大约三小时车程的萨尔玛（Selma）探望帕特里克的姐姐。他们已经离开将近一周了，预定于7月19日星期四返回莫比尔。朱莉和丹妮拉讨论了她们接下来的计划。第二天，朱莉打算开车送丹妮拉去银行，然后去珍珠汽车行提车。一旦丹妮拉有了车，她就想去为科拉采购一些学校用品，包括小女孩之前赞不绝口的一个扎染双肩背包。
After that, Daniela planned to meet up with some friends and go out for a celebratory drink. On Thursday, when Cora and the rest of the family were due back, Daniela would return to Julie's to surprise her daughter with the backpack and stay overnight so they could cuddle up together. As they discussed their plans, Daniela barely moved. She apologized to Julie for being so tired, saying, This medicine just makes me really sleepy. On the morning of Tuesday, July 17, 2018, Daniela rose early.
在那之后，丹妮拉计划和几个朋友见面，出去喝一杯庆祝一下。到了周四科拉和其他家人预定返回的那天，丹妮拉将回到朱莉家，用那个双肩背包给女儿一个惊喜，并留宿一晚，这样她们就能依偎在一起了。在讨论计划时，丹妮拉几乎一动不动。她为自己如此疲惫向朱莉道歉，说道：“这药就是让我觉得特别困。”2018年7月17日星期二早晨，丹妮拉起得很早。
All of the paperwork required to finalize her car purchase was in a large envelope that she shoved into her large, satchel-type handbag. Julie then drove Daniela to the bank as planned so she could deposit cash into Julie's account to pay for her car insurance. Just after 11am, Julie dropped Daniela off at Pearl Motors and waited out the front as she signed the paperwork and picked up the keys. Ten minutes later, Daniela finally sat in her Chevy Cruze and got the final rundown on its features.
完成购车最终手续所需的全部文件都装在一个大信封里，她把信封塞进了她那个大号的手提式手袋里。随后，朱莉按计划开车送丹妮拉去银行，以便她将现金存入朱莉的账户来支付车险。上午11点刚过，朱莉把丹妮拉放在珍珠汽车行门外，并在前台等待她签署文件并领取钥匙。十分钟后，丹妮拉终于坐进她的雪佛兰科鲁兹，并了解了各项功能的最后使用说明。
These included a global positioning system, or GPS, that would be attached to the car to track all of Daniela's movements until the car had been paid off. This was designed to make repossession of the car easier if a buyer failed to make their repayments. The GPS plugged into a port under the steering column and would ping the car's location every 4 minutes when it was in motion and every 4 hours when the vehicle wasn't in use. If it became disconnected, the company would receive an alert and would go in search of the car.
其中包括一个全球定位系统（GPS），它将被安装在车上，用于追踪丹妮拉的所有行踪，直到车款付清。这样设计是为了在买家未能还款时更容易收回车辆。GPS插入转向柱下方的端口，在车辆行驶时每4分钟发送一次位置信号，在车辆闲置时每4小时发送一次。如果它被拔掉，公司就会收到警报并会去寻找车辆。
Daniela had signed an acknowledgement that the GPS was there and that she would not attempt to remove it. At 11.35am, Julie waved Daniela off as she left the car yard. From there, Daniela drove the 24 minute journey to her home at the 701 South Apartments Complex on University Boulevard. She hadn't been going out lately, but was determined to celebrate her new purchase. Although it was a Tuesday, Daniela was optimistic she would find someone willing to go out for a few drinks, as most of her friends worked in the hospitality industry.
丹妮拉已经签署了一份确认书，确认GPS存在且她不会试图将其拆除。上午11点35分，朱莉在丹妮拉离开车场时向她挥手告别。从那里出发，丹妮拉开车行驶了24分钟，来到她位于大学大道（University Boulevard）701号南公寓大楼的家。她最近一直没有出门，但决心庆祝自己的新购好物。虽然是星期二，但丹妮拉乐观地认为她能找到愿意出去喝几杯的人，因为她的大多数朋友都在酒店餐饮行业工作。
In addition, the 89th Major League Baseball All-Star Game was on that night and would be televised live, making it more likely that people would be out and about. Mobile was a baseball mad city, having produced more baseball Hall of Famers than any other city in the US outside of New York and Chicago. Daniela remained at home for several hours and in the afternoon, she started making plans for the evening. Just before 4.20pm, she texted her friend and co-worker Hannah to ask if she was at work, as Daniela was thinking of heading over to the mall where PF Changs was located to
此外，第89届美国职业棒球大联盟全明星赛（Major League Baseball All-Star Game）当晚举行并将进行现场电视转播，这使得人们外出的可能性更大。莫比尔是一座对棒球疯狂的城市，它培养出的美国棒球名人堂成员比美国除纽约和芝加哥以外的任何其他城市都要多。丹妮拉在家呆了几个小时，到了下午，她开始筹划晚上的安排。下午4点20分左右，她给朋友兼同事汉娜发短信，问她是否在上班，因为丹妮拉正考虑去P.F. Chang's所在的购物中心
buy Kora's school supplies. Hannah responded that she would be starting work at 5 o'clock. A few minutes later, Daniela sent a Facebook message to Randy Capps, a former co-worker she used to work with at a bar called Hurricane Grill and Wings. As the bar was in the same area as her errands, Daniela considered stopping by for a drink. She responded that he was indeed working that night, but he now worked at Hero's Sports Bar and Grill, where she would be welcomed to come by. Daniela responded, but I don't like it going to a place I've never been before.
购买科拉的学校用品。汉娜回复说她将在5点钟开始上班。几分钟后，丹妮拉给兰迪·卡普斯（Randy Capps）发送了一条Facebook消息，兰迪是她以前在一家名为“飓风烧烤与鸡翅”（Hurricane Grill and Wings）的酒吧工作时的前同事。由于这家酒吧在她办事的同一区域，丹妮拉考虑顺便去喝一杯。他回复说他当晚确实在上班，不过他现在在“英雄体育酒吧餐厅”（Hero's Sports Bar and Grill）工作，欢迎她过去。丹妮拉回复说，但我不喜欢去一个我从没去过的地方。
Hurricanes is just along the way of whatever responsible things I have to get done so I can stop by and drink mid-bill paying. Randy replied, Ella, well, I hear ya, well, I'm here, not like you don't know anyone. At 5.20pm, Daniela left her apartment, dressed casually in black leggings, a dark colored shirt with a mellow mushroom pizza chain logo on the pocket, and black high-top converse sneakers. Her ever-changing hair was currently dark brown with red tips around the fringe, and she wore it up in a ponytail.
“飓风”就在我要办的正事顺路上，所以我可以在付账的中途顺便去喝一杯。兰迪回复道：“埃拉，好吧，我听说了，好吧，我在那儿，又不是你谁都不认识。”下午5点20分，丹妮拉离开公寓，穿着休闲的黑色打底裤、一件深色衬衫（口袋上印有“浓郁蘑菇”比萨连锁店的标志）以及黑色高帮匡威运动鞋。她那经常变换的发色此时是深棕色，刘忌周围带有红色挑染，她把头发扎成了马尾辫。
She also wore a pink baseball cap that had a cartoon donut sewn on the front, the type favoured by cartoon character Homer Simpson. Daniela stopped at a small strip mall on University Drive before continuing to the shop's mall at Bel Air at 5.50pm, a shopping centre offering a mix of department stores, specialty shops, cafes and restaurants. P.F. Chang's sits on the outside of the mall, just to the right of the main entrance. At the mall, Daniela bumped into a co-worker and the two had a brief exchange, with Daniela saying how relieved she was to finally have a car.
她还戴了一顶粉色棒球帽，前面缝着一个卡通甜甜圈，这是卡通人物荷马·辛普森（Homer Simpson）最喜欢的那种款式。丹妮拉在大学大道（University Drive）的一个小型商业街停留了一下，然后于下午5点50分继续前往贝尔空气购物中心（Bel Air），这是一个集百货公司、专卖店、咖啡馆和餐厅于一体的购物中心。P.F. Chang's位于购物中心的外侧，就在正入口的右侧。在购物中心，丹妮拉偶遇了一位同事，两人进行了短暂的交流，丹妮拉说她终于有了一辆车，感到如释重负。
She couldn't stop to chat long because she was on a mission to buy Cora her backpack for school. After she was done shopping, Daniela made the 18-minute journey to Hero's Sports Bar and Grill, where her former colleague Randy was on duty behind the bar. At 35 years old, Randy was 10 years older than Daniela. He had a checkered past with previous arrests for drug possession, possession of stolen property and driving under the influence. Just after 6.30pm, Daniela settled in at the bar where she could chat to Randy between
她不能停下来聊太久，因为她有购买科拉学校背包的任务在身。买完东西后，丹妮拉驱车18分钟来到了“英雄体育酒吧餐厅”，她的前同事兰迪正在吧台后值班。35岁的兰迪比丹妮拉大10岁。他有着斑驳的过去，曾因藏毒、藏匿赃物和酒后驾驶而被捕。傍晚6点30分刚过，丹妮拉在吧台安顿下来，这样她可以在兰迪
him serving drinks. Hero's was a large sports bar with multiple televisions screening various sporting events. The two chatted, and before long, two more of Randy's friends entered the bar and sat nearby. They were Denson White, who was aged in his early 40s, and Mallory Miller Kenworthy, who was in her mid-30s. Denson, Mallory and Randy all played on the same softball team. There was supposed to be a game that night, but it had been called off due to the rain,
端饮料的间隙和他聊天。英雄酒吧是一个大型体育酒吧，有多台电视播放各种体育赛事。两人闲聊起来，不久之后，兰迪另外两个朋友也进入酒吧并在附近坐下。他们是年过四十的登森·怀特（Denson White）和三十岁出头的马洛里·米勒·肯沃西（Mallory Miller Kenworthy）。登森、马洛里和兰迪都在同一支垒球队打球。那天晚上本该有一场比赛，但因为下雨取消了，
so Mallory and Denson had decided to go to Hero's to watch the All-Stars game. Denson, Mallory and Daniela sat together, watching the game and chatting to Randy while he worked behind the bar. It was Daniela's first time meeting Denson, but she and Mallory had met before as they had friends in the same social circles. Mallory had a newborn baby, and like Daniela, it was her first night out since giving birth six weeks earlier. Denson had just returned from a work trip away and had driven to Hero's in his rental
所以马洛里和登森决定去英雄酒吧看全明星赛。登森、马洛里和丹妮拉坐在一起，一边看比赛，一边和在吧台工作的兰迪聊天。这是丹妮拉第一次见到登森，但她和马洛里以前见过面，因为她们在同一个社交圈里有共同的朋友。马洛里有一个刚出生的婴儿，和丹妮拉一样，这也是她自六周前分娩以来的第一个夜晚外出。登森刚刚结束一次工作差旅回来，是开着租来的车
car. He worked for APM terminals at the Mobile Port, a busy dock where 1,200 shipping containers went in and out on an average day. Denson was a dealmaker who had received many honors for the business he brought into Mobile. At 7.14pm, Daniela responded to a text from Julie regarding some local gossip. One minute later, at 7.15pm, she messaged her friend and colleague, Hannah, to say she hadn't seen her car near PF Changs when she stopped at the mall. Hannah responded that she was indeed working that evening.
来到英雄酒吧的。他在莫比尔港的APM码头（APM terminals）工作，这是一个繁忙的码头，平均每天有1,200个集装箱进出。登森是一个善于谈成生意的能手，他为莫比尔带来的业务赢得了许多荣誉。晚上7点14分，丹妮拉回复了朱莉关于一些当地八卦的短信。一分钟后的7点15分，她给朋友兼同事汉娜发信息，说她去购物中心时没在P.F. Chang's附近看到她的车。汉娜回复说她当晚确实在上班。
At 7.36pm, Daniela messaged Hannah again, saying, I'm drinking happily at a sports bar. To which Hannah replied, hell yes, taking advantage of the freedom. Daniela, Mallory and Denson made plans to move on to Dublin pub and eatery just half a mile down the road. It was an Irish themed bar that had opened two months earlier, with live music and a lot more atmosphere than Hero's. They agreed to meet Randy at a third bar, Oli's Mediterranean Grill, when he finished
晚上7点36分，丹妮拉再次给汉娜发信息，说：“我在一家体育酒吧开心地喝着呢。”汉娜回复道：“太棒了，好好享受自由吧。”丹妮拉、马洛里和登森计划转往离此仅半英里远的“都柏林酒吧餐厅”（Dublin pub and eatery）。那是一家爱尔兰主题酒吧，两个月前刚开业，有现场音乐，氛围比英雄酒吧浓郁得多。他们同意等兰迪那天晚上晚些时候下班后，在第三家酒吧——“奥利地中海烧烤”（Oli's Mediterranean Grill）与他会合。
work later that night. Oli's was another former workplace of Daniela's and was closer to her apartment. She expected to finish work around 11pm and said he would text them when he was leaving. At 8.25pm, Daniela sent a text to Hannah that read, Okay, I'm going to drive now, but should I? I don't know. She had consumed a few drinks while at Hero's but didn't appear to be drunk. However, it's possible that she may have taken a couple of her Norco painkillers which
奥利餐厅是丹妮拉的另一家前工作单位，距离她的公寓更近。她预计晚上11点左右下班，并说他离开时会给他们发短信。晚上8点25分，丹妮拉给汉娜发了一条短信：“好吧，我现在要开车了，但我是不是该开？我不知道。”她在英雄酒吧时喝了几杯酒，但看起来并没有醉。不过，她有可能服用了几片Norco止痛药，
could result in serious side effects when mixed with alcohol. At 8.57pm, Daniela and Denson became Facebook friends and Denson sent Daniela an invitation to a party at his house that was to be held a couple of weeks later. At 9.12pm, Daniela hugged Randy goodbye and she, Denson and Mallory left Hero's for their next destination. As soon as Daniela was outside, she sent two Facebook messages to Randy but he didn't respond to either. At 9.16pm, she attempted to call Hannah, who was still working and didn't answer.
这与酒精混合可能会导致严重的副作用。晚上8点57分，丹妮拉和登森成为Facebook好友，登森向丹妮拉发出了邀请，请她参加几周后在他家举办的一个派对。晚上9点12分，丹妮拉拥抱了兰迪作为告别，她、登森和马洛里离开英雄酒吧前往下一个目的地。丹妮拉一到室外，就给兰迪发了两条Facebook消息，但他两条都没回。晚上9点16分，她试图打电话给汉娜，汉娜当时还在上班，没有接听。
At 9.46pm, Daniela sent Hannah a short video via the messaging app Snapchat of her sitting alone in the driver's seat of her car. The clip contained nothing out of the ordinary, although Hannah did notice that Daniela appeared to be a little intoxicated. As is the case with Snapchat messages, the video played once before being automatically deleted. Hannah tried to call Daniela shortly afterwards but there was no answer. According to the GPS records in Daniela's car, she left the Hero's car park at 10.05pm,
晚上9点46分，丹妮拉通过聊天应用Snapchat给汉娜发了一个短视频，视频中她独自坐在自己车的驾驶座上。这段短片没有什么不寻常之处，不过汉娜确实注意到丹妮拉看起来有点醉意。正如Snapchat消息的情况一样，视频播放一次后便被自动删除。此后不久汉娜试图回电话给丹妮拉，但无人接听。根据丹妮拉车上的GPS记录，她于晚上10点05分离开英雄酒吧停车场，
nearly one hour after exiting the bar. It isn't known whether she stayed in the car park by herself the entire time or caught a lift to Dublin's earlier with Denson or Mallory before returning for her car later. At 10.08pm, Daniela's car pulled into Dublin's where she continued socializing with Denson and Mallory. At some point, Mallory announced that she was going to a pool hall called the Runway Bar to catch up with friends and would meet up with Daniela, Denson and Randy later at Ollie's. However, Denson said he had decided to go home instead of continuing on.
距离她走出酒吧将近一个小时。目前尚不清楚她是一直独自留在停车场，还是早些时候和登森或马洛里搭车去了都柏林酒吧，稍后再回来取车。晚上10点08分，丹妮拉的车驶入都柏林酒吧，她在那里继续与登森和马洛里社交。某个时候，马洛里宣布她要去一家名为“跑道酒吧”（Runway Bar）的台球厅与朋友叙旧，稍后会在奥利餐厅与丹妮拉、登森和兰迪会合。然而，登森说他决定回家，不再继续去了。
At 10.44pm, Randy sent Daniela a Facebook message to let her know he was about to finish work and would head straight to Ollie's. One minute later, at 10.45pm, Daniela, Denson and Mallory each left Dublin's in their separate vehicles. Randy arrived at Ollie's three minutes later. Unable to find the group, he called Denson at 10.57pm but there was no answer so he settled in to wait for the others to arrive. The drive from Dublin's to Ollie's was only 2.8 miles and required a left turn out of
晚上10点44分，兰迪给丹妮拉发了一条Facebook消息，让她知道他快下班了，将直接前往奥利餐厅。一分钟后的晚上10点45分，丹妮拉、登森和马洛里分别驾驶各自的车辆离开都柏林酒吧。兰迪三分钟后到达奥利餐厅。由于找不到这群人，他在晚上10点57分打电话给登森，但无人接听，于是他安顿下来等待其他人到达。从都柏林酒吧到奥利餐厅只有2.8英里，出停车场时需要左转。
the car park. Denson's house was in the opposite direction and required a right turn. According to the GPS data from Daniela's car, upon leaving the car park, she also took a right turn, which was odd given she knew the area incredibly well and was fully aware that Ollie's was in the opposite direction. Mallory saw this manoeuvre and noted it as strange but continued on to the Runway Bar to meet her friends without giving it much thought. Denson later said he wasn't aware that Daniela was following him until 15 minutes later when
登森的家在相反的方向，需要右转。根据丹妮拉车的GPS数据，她离开停车场时也向右转了，这很奇怪，因为她对该地区极为熟悉，并且完全知道奥利餐厅在相反的方向。马洛里看到了这个行车动作，觉得很奇怪，但并没有过多考虑，便继续前往跑道酒吧与朋友会面。登森后来表示，直到15分钟后
they were passing through a quiet industrial area and she flashed her lights to indicate she wanted him to pull over. Although there were open gas stations at a waffle house nearby, at 11.05pm, the two cars pulled into a dark, closed shell gas station at 35.50 government boulevard in Mobile. Once they stopped, Daniela told Denson that she had lost her mobile phone. At 11.07pm, the GPS in her car made its final location call. The GPS installed by Pearl Motors was plugged securely into an outlet underneath the steering wheel and was highly unlikely to come out accidentally.
她们正穿过一个安静的工业区，她闪烁大灯示意他把车停路边。尽管附近有一家Waffle House华夫饼屋旁边有开着的加油站，但在晚上11点05分，两辆车还是开进莫比尔政府大道35.50号一个黑暗且已经关门的壳牌加油站。车停下后，丹妮拉告诉登森她的手机不见了。晚上11点07分，她车上的GPS发出了最后一次位置呼叫。由珍珠汽车公司安装的GPS牢固地插在方向盘下方的插座里，极其不可能意外脱落。
The fact that it made its final signal at 11.07pm indicated it had either been unplugged or that a fuse had blown, either coincidentally or because it had been tampered with. After this, it stopped sending locations back to the base. Denson then called Daniela's phone via Facebook Messenger. It is unclear why he did this instead of dialing her number, but the most likely reason is that Daniela had a habit of losing and changing phones and hadn't yet memorized her own number. It would have been even more difficult for her to remember if she was under the influence. Meanwhile, Mallory had arrived at Olly's after a short stop at the runway bar and was
它在晚上11点07分发出最后一次信号，这表明它要么被拔掉了，要么是保险丝烧断了——不管是巧合还是因为被人动了手脚。在此之后，它停止向基站发送位置信息。随后，登森通过Facebook Messenger给丹妮拉的手机打了电话。目前还不清楚他为什么这么做而不是直接拨打她的号码，但最有可能的原因是丹妮拉有丢手机和换手机的习惯，而且还没记住自己的号码。如果她当时喝了酒或受了酒精影响，那就更难记住了。与此同时，马洛里在跑道酒吧短暂停留后，已经来到了奥利酒吧，正
sitting with Randy waiting for Daniela to arrive. At 11.17pm, Denson called Randy, explaining that Daniela had lost her phone and he was going back to Dublin's to look for it. At 11.24pm, both Daniela and Denson's car drove out of the Shell gas station and turned towards Dublin's. Daniela followed Denson for a while before making a turn towards a more populated part of town. Just over 10 minutes later, at 11.37pm, Denson sent Mallory a text message from Dublin's
和兰迪坐在一起等待丹妮拉的到来。晚上11点17分，登森给兰迪打电话，解释说丹妮拉把手机弄丢了，他要回都柏林酒吧去找。晚上11点24分，丹妮拉和登森的车双双开出壳牌加油站，朝都柏林酒吧驶去。丹妮拉跟了登森一会儿，然后转弯驶向镇上人口较多的地方。仅仅10分钟多一点后，即晚上11点37分，登森从都柏林酒吧给马洛里发了一条短信，
that contained a selfie of him standing at the bar. Underneath the photo, he wrote, Getting phone, just got back here, but somehow lost to Daniela. A server at Dublin's had found Daniela's phone on the back of a car and placed it behind the bar for safekeeping. Denson retrieved it from the bartender and at 11.52pm, he called Daniela via Facebook Messenger. It's unclear why he tried to do so considering he had her phone and she presumably had no
里面附了一张他在酒吧吧台前的自拍。照片下方他写道：“找手机呢，刚回到这儿，不过不知怎么把丹妮拉给跟丢了。”都柏林酒吧的一名服务员在一辆汽车的后车身上找到了丹妮拉的手机，并把它放在吧台后面保管。登森从酒保那里取回了手机，并在晚上11点52分通过Facebook Messenger给丹妮拉打了电话。目前尚不清楚他为什么还要这么做，考虑到他当时拿着她的手机，而她想必也没有
way of answering the call. When there was no answer, Denson wrote Daniela a Facebook message that read, Call me, Dublin had your phone. At approximately midnight, Denson drove to Wally's, where Randy and Mallory told him that Daniela hadn't shown up. At 12.04pm and then again at 12.33am, Denson attempted video calling Daniela via Facebook Messenger. When there was no response, he asked Randy what to do with the phone.
办法接听电话。见无人接听，登森给丹妮拉发了一条Facebook消息：“给我回电，都柏林酒吧有你的手机。”大约午夜时分，登森开车来到沃利酒吧，兰迪和马洛里在那里告诉他丹妮拉一直没出现。晚上12点04分，接着又在晚上12点33分，登森试图通过Facebook Messenger给丹妮拉进行视频通话。在没有任何回应的情况下，他问兰迪该怎么处理这个手机。
Randy suggested that Denson take it to PF Chang's the next day, where Daniela could be reunited with it on her next shift. Denson agreed and left Dublin's, taking Daniela's phone with him. At 7.30 the next morning of Wednesday, July 18, Hannah sent Daniela a text message asking if she was okay. Assuming her friend had had a big night out, Hannah didn't expect to receive a response right away and after sending the text, she went about her day. At the same time, Julie Thomas received a phone call from Denson to say he had found
兰迪建议登森第二天把它带到PF陈餐馆，这样丹妮拉在下次轮班时就能跟手机重聚了。登森表示同意，随后离开了都柏林酒吧，把丹妮拉的手机带走了。第二天（7月18日星期三）早上7点30分，汉娜给丹妮拉发了一条短信，问她是否还好。汉娜以为她的朋友昨晚玩得很嗨，并没有指望立刻收到回复，发完短信后她便开始忙自己的事了。与此同时，朱莉·托马斯接到了登森打来的电话，说他找到了
Daniela's phone. He gave no indication that he knew Daniela personally or had been with her the previous night. Julie was under the impression that he was a complete stranger. She told Denson to drop the phone off at Daniela's workplace, but he didn't follow this suggestion. Instead, he called Julie twice more throughout the course of the day. She eventually told him to just hang on to the phone and that Daniela would be in touch
丹妮拉的手机。他没有透露任何自己认识丹妮拉本人或者昨晚曾和她在一起的迹象。朱莉以为他完全是个陌生人。她让登森把手机送到丹妮拉的工作单位，但他没有听从这个建议。相反，他在这一天当中又给朱莉打过两次电话。她最后告诉他拿着手机就行，等丹妮拉露面后自然会联系他。
once she reappeared. On Thursday, July 19, Julie's husband Patrick, son PJ, and granddaughter Cora returned home from their week-long visit to see Patrick's family. Over lunch, Cora told Julie all about the trip away. As the afternoon wore on, Julie anticipated Daniela would walk through the door at any moment. Although Daniela was often late for her visits, Julie expected that she would have turned up in time to welcome Cora home after a week away and couldn't help but be annoyed by
7月19日星期四，朱莉的丈夫帕特里克、儿子PJ以及孙女科拉结束了对帕特里克家为期一周的探亲之旅回到了家中。午饭时，科拉向朱莉滔滔不绝地讲起了这次外出旅行。随着下午过去，朱莉预期丹妮拉随时都会走进门来。尽管丹妮拉探访时经常迟到，但朱莉原本预计她会赶在科拉一周外出一回来时露面表示欢迎，并忍不住对她的
her tardiness. When Thursday night rolled around and there was still no word from Daniela, Julie started to worry. Cora had been tucked safely in bed without a good night kiss from her mother, which was highly unusual. Despite any other issues going on in Daniela's life, she was loving and reliable when it came to her daughter. Julie tried privately messaging Daniela on Facebook, which was Daniela's preferred method
迟到感到有些恼火。当周四夜晚降临，依然没有任何丹妮拉的消息时，朱莉开始担心起来。科拉已经被安顿妥当送上床睡觉了，却连母亲的一句晚安吻都没有得到，这极其反常。抛开丹妮拉生活中的其他问题不谈，她在对待女儿这件事上一直是充满爱心且靠谱的。朱莉试着在Facebook上私信丹妮拉，这是丹妮拉首选的
of contact. She kept checking to see whether there was a response, but the message hadn't been viewed, and Facebook indicated it had been two days since Daniela was last active. Unsure what else to do, Julie posted a message for Daniela on her public Facebook feed, asking her to get in touch. When Daniela's friend Hannah arrived at work that evening, one of her colleagues asked if she had spoken to Daniela, as no one had been able to get a hold of her. Hannah realized she had never received a response to the text message she'd sent to
联系方式。她不停地查看是否有回复，但消息并未被已读，Facebook显示丹妮拉上一次活跃已经是在两天前了。朱莉不知还能做些什么，便在自己公开的Facebook动态上发了一条寻找丹妮拉的消息，请她与大家取得联系。当天傍晚，当丹妮拉的朋友汉娜到达单位时，一位同事问她是否跟丹妮拉说过话，因为谁也联系不上她。汉娜这才意识到，自己发给
Daniela the previous morning. She texted her again via phone and Facebook Messenger, but received no response. Sensing something was wrong, Hannah messaged mutual friends to see if anyone had heard from Daniela. One person responded that on Tuesday night, Daniela had mentioned she was going to Hero's Sportsbar and Grill. Hannah called Heroes and asked the manager to check the car park for a dark blue Chevy cruise, but there was no car there matching that description.
丹妮拉昨天早上的短信至今没有收到任何回复。她再次通过手机和Facebook Messenger发信息给她，但依然没有回应。汉娜察觉到有些不对劲，便给共同的朋友发消息，看有没有人听到过丹妮拉的消息。一个人回复说，周二晚上，丹妮拉曾提过她要去英雄运动酒吧餐厅（Hero's Sportsbar and Grill）。汉娜打电话给英雄酒吧，请经理帮忙检查停车场有没有一辆深蓝色雪佛兰科鲁兹，但那里并没有符合该描述的车辆。
The manager offered to check who had been working on Tuesday night to see if anyone recalled seeing Daniela. He called Hannah back shortly after to say that the bartender on duty, Randy Capps, confirmed that Daniela had been at Heroes and had been hanging out with Denson White and Mallory Miller Kenworthy. Hannah didn't know Denson, but was able to track him down through Facebook. At 9.17pm on Thursday, July 19, she sent him a Facebook message that said, Hey, I'm Daniela's friend.
经理主动提出查看一下周二晚上的值班人员，看是否有人记起见过丹妮拉。不久后他回电话给汉娜，称当班酒保兰迪·卡普斯确认丹妮拉确实去过英雄酒吧，并且曾和登森·怀特以及马洛里·米勒·肯沃西在一起。汉娜不认识登森，但她通过Facebook追踪到了他。7月19日星期四晚上9点17分，她给他发了一条Facebook消息：“嗨，我是丹妮拉的朋友。
We haven't heard from her since Tuesday night, and we are all very concerned. If you know where she could be at, or have any information, please message me back. Later that night, Denson called Hannah to say that he hadn't seen Daniela since Tuesday night, but he had her phone and had been trying to return it to her. Afterwards, Hannah drove to Daniela's apartment, but found no sign of her there. She sent another message to Daniela on Facebook that said, Hey, what's up? Everybody's worried. The next morning of Friday, July 20, Hannah drove by Daniela's apartment on her way to
我们从周二晚上起就联系不上她了，大家都很担心。如果你知道她在哪里，或者有任何信息，请给我回信。”当晚晚些时候，登森给汉娜回电话称，他自周二晚上以来就没见过丹妮拉，但他有她的手机，并且一直在试图把它还给她。随后，汉娜开车去了丹妮拉的公寓，但在那里没有发现她的踪迹。她又在Facebook上给丹妮拉发了一条消息：“嗨，怎么回事？大家都很担心。”第二天（7月20日星期五）清晨，汉娜在去美容学校的路上开车路过了
cosmetology school, but it was clear that she hadn't been home. Daniela was scheduled to work at 10am shift at PF Changs, so Hannah dropped by the restaurant to see if she had shown up. Realizing she hadn't, Hannah called Julie and then messaged Denson to let them know that there was still no sign of Daniela. Julie, Hannah and Denson exchanged a flurry of calls and text messages and decided it was time to report Daniela missing. Although it wasn't unusual for the fun-loving 25-year-old to be out of contact for a day
丹妮拉的公寓，但显然她根本没有回过家。丹妮拉原定于上午10点在PF陈餐馆（PF Chang's）上班，于是汉娜顺道去了餐厅，看她是否来上班了。意识到她没有出现后，汉娜打电话给朱莉，并给登森发了信息，告知他们依然没有任何丹妮拉的踪迹。朱莉、汉娜和登森互通了一连串的电话和短信，最后决定是时候去报案说丹妮拉失踪了。尽管这个爱好玩乐的25岁女孩失联一天
or two, the fact she had missed work and hadn't shown up to greet her daughter were both major red flags. Julie and Denson arranged to meet at the police station on Airport Boulevard and Doors, where Julie could file a missing persons report and Denson could hand over the phone and make a statement. Once there, they were instructed to go to the office on Government Street where the missing persons liaison unit was located. On the way, Julie called Hannah to ask if she knew the six-digit number to unlock Daniela's
或两天并不罕见，但她无故旷工且没有露面迎接女儿回家，这两点都是亮起的重大红旗。朱莉和登森约定在机场大道（Airport Boulevard）和多尔斯（Doors）的警察局碰头，朱莉可以在那里提交失踪人口报告，而登森则可以交出手机并做一份笔录。到了那里后，他们被指示前往位于政府街（Government Street）的失踪人口联络处办公室。在路上，朱莉打电话给汉娜，问她是否知道解锁丹妮拉
phone. Hannah advised that it was Daniela's employee number and she gave this number to Julie. Once Julie had unlocked the phone, she read through all of the text messages Daniela had sent and received during the past week and also listened to her voicemail. By the time Julie arrived at the missing persons liaison unit, Denson had provided his statement to the police. Hannah also arrived to make a statement about how out of character it was for Daniela to be out of contact for so long and not to show for her shift when she needed money the most.
手机的六位数密码。汉娜告知那是丹妮拉的员工编号，并将这个数字告诉了朱莉。朱莉解锁手机后，翻看了过去一周里丹妮拉发送和接收的所有短信，还听了她的语音信箱。等朱莉到达失踪人口联络处时，登森已经向警方做完了笔录。汉娜也赶到了，她做了一份笔录，说明丹妮拉失联这么久以及在最需要钱的时候无故旷工是多么反常的行为。
Julie provided as much information as she could and surrendered Daniela's phone to the police. An officer later accompanied her to Daniela's apartment where a crime scene officer met them to conduct an assessment but nothing seemed to be missing or out of the ordinary. When Julie returned home, she logged on to her computer where Daniela had saved the login details for her various social media accounts. She signed into Daniela's Facebook account where she noticed several missed calls from Denson White.
朱莉尽可能多地提供了信息，并将丹妮拉的手机交给了警方。随后，一名警官陪同她来到丹妮拉的公寓，一名犯罪现场勘查警官在那里与他们会合并进行评估，但看起来没有任何东西丢失或有异常情况。朱莉回到家后，登录了她的电脑——丹妮拉在上面保存了她各个社交媒体账户的登录信息。她登录了丹妮拉的Facebook账户，注意到上面有几个登森·怀特打来的未接来电。
At 11.11pm on the night Daniela was last seen, just minutes after the GPS on her car pinged for the last time, Denson's Facebook account had left a voice message to Daniela's account. It appeared to have been left by accident and featured rustling noises accompanied by a female voice, believed to be Daniela's. Warning, some listeners may find the following audio clip distressing. A minute later, another seemingly accidental voice message was left from Denson's Facebook account to Daniela's, featuring much of the same rustling noises as well as a muffled male voice speaking to the female and instructing her not to touch something.
在丹妮拉最后一次露面当晚的晚上11点11分，即她车上的GPS最后一次发出信号几分钟后，登森的Facebook账户曾给丹妮拉的账户留下一条语音消息。这条语音似乎是意外留下的，里面伴随着沙沙的摩擦声和一个女性的声音，据信是丹妮拉的声音。警告：部分听众可能会觉得接下来的音频片段令人不安。一分钟后，登森的Facebook账户又向丹妮拉的账户留下了另一条看似意外的语音消息，其中包含大量相同的沙沙声，还有一个低沉的男性声音在对女性说话，指示她不要碰某样东西。
Julie called the police to tell them about the voice messages and they advised her not to log back in to Daniela's Facebook account in case it tainted evidence. When Julie inquired about CCTV footage that may have been captured at the various locations Daniela had visited, the police told her no such footage had been found. Julie was therefore shocked when a news outlet reporting on Daniela's disappearance featured CCTV footage from the Shell gas station where the last confirmed sighting of her had taken place. The footage was dark and grainy with poor visibility but it showed a car pull in at
朱莉打电话给警察告知了这些语音消息的事，警方建议她不要再次登录丹妮拉的Facebook账户，以免破坏证据。当朱莉询问在丹妮拉去过的各个地点是否拍到过监控录像时，警方告诉她没有找到此类监控。因此，当一家报道丹妮拉失踪的新闻机构播出了确认能看到她最后踪迹的壳牌加油站的监控画面时，朱莉感到十分震惊。画面又黑又糊，可见度很差，但它显示一辆车在
the Shell at 11.05pm. Seconds later, another car pulled in beside the first. A couple of minutes later, the second car left and then immediately after, another one pulled in. Given the poor quality, it was impossible to tell whether the second car had left and returned or if a different third vehicle drove in after the second car departed. No people were visible in the footage due to its poor quality. Julie called the police demanding to know why the footage was being aired on television
晚上11点05分驶入壳牌加油站。几秒钟后，另一辆车驶入并停在第一辆车旁边。几分钟后，第二辆车离开，紧接着又有一辆车驶入。由于画质太差，根本无法分辨第二辆车是离开后又折返了，还是在第二辆车离开后又开进了一辆不同的第三辆车。由于画质恶劣，画面中看不到任何人影。朱莉打电话给警察，质问为什么在被告知没有监控画面的时候，
when she was told that no footage existed. Rather than responding, law enforcement officials contacted the news station and demanded the footage be removed. The news outlet complied but no further explanation was given for the police action. On Tuesday, July 24, less than one week after Daniela was last seen, Julie and her husband Patrick attended court to finalize custody arrangements for Cora. This process had already been going on for several months prior to Daniela's disappearance, with Daniela's full cooperation, and a majority of the paperwork had already been signed and
电视上却在播送这些录像。执法官员没有回答，而是联系了新闻台并要求将其撤下。这家新闻机构照做了，但对于警方的这一行为没有给出进一步的解释。7月24日星期二，即丹妮拉最后一次露面不到一周后，朱莉和丈夫帕特里克出庭敲定科拉的抚养权归属。这一程序在丹妮拉失踪前就已经进行了好几个月，并且得到了丹妮拉的全力配合，大部分文书工作都已经签署并
filed. The plan had been that Daniela would give Julie and Patrick full custody of Cora until she could get her life in order. It was clear from Daniela's journal entries about organizing Cora's bedroom and having her sleep over 80% of the time that she hoped to regain custody sooner rather than later. Daniela had always planned to attend the court hearing, but as she didn't show up, Julie and Patrick were awarded custody of Cora. The following day, Tyler was released from jail and returned to the apartment he shared
归档了。原本的计划是，在丹妮拉把自己的生活理顺之前，由朱莉和帕特里克完全抚养科拉。从丹妮拉整理科拉的卧室以及让科拉80%的时间都在她那里过夜的日记内容中，可以清楚地看出她希望能尽快重新获得抚养权。丹妮拉原本计划出庭，但由于她没有露面，法庭将科拉的抚养权判给了朱莉和帕特里克。第二天，泰勒从监狱获释，回到了他和
with Daniela. They immediately took the few items of value that Daniela owned, including her video gaming system and television, and pawned them. When Julie found out, she bought the items back. That same day, the Mobile Police confirmed that the case had been handed over to the Homicide Squad. They also released a statement clarifying that while homicide detectives were involved, there wasn't any evidence to suggest that a homicide had occurred.
丹妮拉合租的公寓。他们立刻拿走了丹妮拉仅有的几件有价值的物品，包括她的电子游戏机和电视机，并把它们当铺了。朱莉发现后，把这些东西赎了回来。同一天，莫比尔警方证实该案件已移交给凶杀组。他们还发布了一份声明澄清说，尽管凶杀案侦探介入了此案，但目前没有任何证据表明发生过凶杀案。
As the GPS device was no longer functioning on Daniela's car, Pearl Motors hadn't been able to track its location and there had been no reported sightings of the Chevy crews anywhere. Investigators were monitoring Daniela's bank account activity and were alerted that her Visa debit card had been used at a gas station. However, this was linked back to Tyler, who had found the debit card when he had gone through the apartment. Hannah had been a frequent visitor to Daniela's apartment and on Friday, July 27, Tyler gave her a key and asked if she noticed anything unusual or out of place.
由于丹妮拉车上的GPS设备已经无法工作，珍珠汽车公司无法追踪其位置，且各处也没有接到过关于这辆雪佛兰科鲁兹的目击报告。调查人员一直在监控丹妮拉的银行账户活动，并接到警报称她的Visa借记卡在一个加油站被使用过。然而，这追查到了泰勒头上，他在整理公寓时发现了这张借记卡。汉娜曾是丹妮拉公寓的常客，7月27日星期五，泰勒给了她一把钥匙，并问她有没有发现什么不寻常或不对劲的地方。
Daniela noted that all of Daniela's possessions were still there, including her makeup, clothes and her phone charger. It was not the scene of someone who had chosen to run away. The police also searched the apartment. Daniela kept a whiteboard with a record of her goals and the amount of money she had saved so that she could keep track of her progress. Based on the figures on the board, Daniela had around $1200 cash left in savings, but if that money was in the apartment, there is no official record of it being found.
丹妮拉（注：原文此处疑为叙述笔误指代汉娜或朱莉，按语境应指汉娜）注意到丹妮拉的所有财物都还在，包括她的化妆品、衣服和手机充电器。这绝不是一个选择离家出走的人会留下的现场。警察也搜查了公寓。丹妮拉有一个白板，上面记录着她的目标以及她存下的钱数，以便追踪自己的进度。根据白板上的数字，丹妮拉还剩下大约1200美元的现金储蓄，但如果这笔钱在公寓里，官方并没有找到它的记录。
Tyler was unable to maintain the apartment's rental payments and was soon evicted. The building manager wouldn't allow Julie in to collect Daniela's possessions, instead dumping them unceremoniously on the pavement outside and letting Julie know she could come and collect them. Julie went directly over to pick up everything Daniela owned, then she and Tyler examined all of the items, but they found no clues as to where Daniela might be. On Friday, September 14, almost two months since Daniela's disappearance, Mobile Police responded to a complaint of unlawful imprisonment and sexual abuse at a home in the town of
泰勒无力支付公寓的房租，不久就被驱逐了。物业经理不允许朱莉进去收捡丹妮拉的物品，而是毫不客气地把它们倒在外面的路面上，并通知朱莉可以来拿走。朱莉直接过去把丹妮拉拥有的所有东西都捡了回来，随后她和泰勒检查了所有的物品，但没有找到任何关于丹妮拉可能在哪里的线索。9月14日星期五，距离丹妮拉失踪将近两个月之际，莫比尔警方接到了一起位于
Theodore, 14 miles south of Mobile. Three people were detained and a man named Jason Corey Dykes was arrested on charges of domestic violence, strangulation, assault and unlawful imprisonment. Jason, who was Julie Dykes Thomas' nephew, was accused of locking a former girlfriend in a room where he beat and raped her. According to multiple sources, the alleged victim claimed that Jason had said something threatening about Daniela Vianne. However, a raid of the property turned up nothing of interest in the Vianne investigation
莫比尔以南14英里处的西奥多（Theodore）镇一处住宅内发生非法拘禁和性虐待的报案。三人被扣留，一名叫杰森·科里·戴克斯（Jason Corey Dykes）的男子因涉嫌家庭暴力、扼喉、攻击和非法拘禁而被捕. 杰森是朱莉·戴克斯·托马斯的侄女（注：原文侄子/外甥），他被指控将前女友锁在一个房间里进行殴打和强奸。据多方消息来源称，这位声称受害者（注：原文如此）宣称杰森曾说过关于丹妮拉·维安妮的威胁性言论。然而，对该房产的突击搜查在维安妮的调查中没有搜出任何有价值的东西，
and police determined that Jason's alleged crimes were unrelated to Daniela's disappearance. The allegations were later proven to be false and Jason was cleared of all charges and ruled out as a person of interest in Daniela's investigation. Daniela's loved ones were frustrated by the lack of progress in the case. Julie set up a GoFundMe campaign to raise money, which she used to print out flyers that were handed out and put into letter boxes in the area. She also had billboards mounted that featured Daniela's photo and details about her disappearance. Just before Christmas, a frustrated hanner left a one-star review on the Mobile Police
并且警方判定杰森涉嫌的罪行与丹妮拉的失踪无关。这些指控后来被证明是虚假的，杰森被洗脱了所有罪名，并被排除在丹妮拉案的涉案嫌疑人之外。丹妮拉的亲人们对案件缺乏进展感到沮丧。朱莉发起了一项GoFundMe众筹活动来筹集资金，她用这些钱印刷了传单，并在该地区的信箱里分发和投递。她还竖起了广告牌，上面印着丹妮拉的照片和她失踪的详细信息。圣诞节前夕，沮丧的汉娜在莫比尔警察局的
Department's Facebook page, writing, Daniela Vianne has been missing for five months. Five months her baby girl hasn't seen her mum. Five months Daniela hasn't gotten to hold her daughter. Five months her family has had to sit around and wonder when we will all get answers. The Mobile Police Department knows who she was with last, but they say they have run out of leads. It's crazy that Mobile Police will post about robberies, stolen property, and post surveillance
Facebook主页上留下了差评，写道：“丹妮拉·维安妮已经失踪五个月了。五个月来，她的宝贝女儿没见过妈妈。五个月来，丹妮拉没能抱一抱她的女儿。五个月来，她的家人只能坐立不安地等待，不知道我们什么时候才能得到答案。莫比尔警察局知道她最后跟谁在一起，但他们却说线索已经断了。太荒谬了，莫比尔警察局会在网上发布关于抢劫、失窃财产的动态，还会发布监控
videos asking for help, but not for Daniela. They post about awards police officers are receiving, but can't post one missing picture of Daniela. They should hand out awards to police officers that find missing people, not stolen property. Daniela was stolen, a person was stolen, not some groceries, a person. I have lost all faith in the Mobile Police Department. I have hope that some way or another Daniela and all the missing girls from Mobile will be found, but it won't be from the help of the Mobile Police Department.
视频请求协助，却唯独不发关于丹妮拉的。他们发布警察获奖的消息，却连一张丹妮拉的失踪寻人启事都发不出来。他们应该把奖项颁发给找回失踪人口的警察，而不是找回失窃财产的警察。丹妮拉被偷走了，是一个人被偷走了，而不是什么杂货，是一个活生生的人。我对莫比尔警察局已经完全失去信心了。我希望不管用什么方法，丹妮拉和莫比尔所有失踪的女孩都能被找到，但这绝对不会是因为莫比尔警察局的帮助。”
They sweep the missing under the rug. Daniela's friends and family maintained pressure on the police to ensure they continued the search. Several vigils had been held since Daniela's disappearance, and on March 8, 2019, 20 of Daniela's loved ones gathered in Medal of Honor Park to commemorate what would have been her 26th birthday. Julie purposefully kept Cora away as she didn't want the young girl to associate birthdays with sadness.
他们把失踪人口案件束之高阁。丹妮拉的朋友和家人持续向警方施压，以确保他们继续搜寻。自从丹妮拉失踪以来，人们已经举行了数次烛光守夜活动。2019年3月8日，20名丹妮拉的亲友聚集在荣誉勋章公园（Medal of Honor Park），纪念本该是她26岁的生日。朱莉特意没有让科拉参加，因为她不想让这个小女孩把生日和悲伤联系在一起。
Although all the local news outlets were informed, only one member of the media attended. A prayer was said, and then candles were lit on cupcakes as Daniela's friends and family saying happy birthday. Months continued to go by without any reported sightings of Daniela or her car, and no further clues emerged. Tyler realized how important it was that Cora received as much support as possible and stepped up in his role as parent. He stopped using drugs and focused on getting a job so he could provide for his daughter,
尽管所有当地新闻媒体都得到了通知，但只有一名媒体记者到场。大家做了一个祈祷，接着在纸杯蛋糕上点燃了蜡烛，丹妮拉的朋友和家人一起唱起了生日快乐歌。数月时间一天天过去，依然没有任何关于丹妮拉或她的车的目击报告，也没有出现进一步的线索。泰勒意识到科拉获得尽可能多的支持是多么重要，于是承担起了做家长的责任。他戒掉了毒品，专注于找工作以养活女儿，
with his love for Cora motivating him to make better decisions. Many theories were put forth by those who knew Daniela and by internet sleuths who became obsessed with the unresolved case. The theories ranged from Daniela running away to start a new life, to accidentally driving her car into a body of water, to ending her own life. The more sinister theories suggested she was the victim of a botched carjacking, that she went to score drugs and was attacked in the process, or was deliberately targeted to settle a debt.
他对科拉的爱促使他做出更好的决定。认识丹妮拉的人以及痴迷于这起未解之案的网络侦探们提出了各种各样的理论。这些理论从丹妮拉离家出走开始新生活、意外将车开进水体，到选择自杀不等。更阴暗的理论则暗示她是一次未遂劫车案的受害者，或者是她去买毒品的过程中遭到袭击，亦或是为了清偿债务而成为被蓄意针对的目标。
One of the more extreme theories was that she fell victim to the sex trafficking trade. No evidence emerged to support any of these. One of the most astonishing details of the case was that Daniela's car hadn't been spotted. As it had only been purchased on the day of her disappearance, it didn't yet have permanent license plates and still bore the dealer tags. While this would have made it easier to spot, it also may have made the car an attractive target for thieves who could give it a new identity in a chop shop.
其中较为极端的理论之一是她沦为了性交易的受害者。没有任何证据支持这些推测。该案中最令人震惊的细节之一是丹妮拉的车一直没有被发现。由于它是在她失踪当天才购买的，因此还没有永久车牌，挂着的仍然是经销商的临时标签。虽然这本应让车更容易被认出，但也可能使这辆车成为窃贼眼中的诱人目标，他们可以在非法拆车厂给它换个“新身份”。
The individuals who were last seen with Daniela, Denson White, Mallory Miller Kenworthy and Randy Capps, all cooperated with the police, but elected not to provide any statements to the media. One day, Julie and to the now five-year-old Cora were driving in the car when Cora suddenly asked, has Mummy passed on? Julie was surprised and asked Cora where she heard such a thing. Cora replied. I've been having dreams about Mummy.
最后和丹妮拉在一起的人——登森·怀特、马洛里·米勒·肯沃西和兰迪·卡普斯——都配合了警方调查，但选择不向媒体发表任何声明。有一天，朱莉正带着现在五岁的科拉开车，科拉突然问道：“妈妈已经过世了吗？”朱莉大吃一惊，问科拉是从哪听说的这种话。科拉回答道：“我一直在做关于妈妈的梦。
I have dreams about her all the time. Mummy said that she's passed on, but she'll still come to see me all the time. Julie said she was unable to answer the question, but reassured Cora that they would keep looking for Daniela no matter what. Although Cora seemed content with understanding that her mother wasn't coming home, Julie was determined to get answers for the young girl, so she didn't spend her whole life trying to find out the truth of what happened. Life went on, with Julie continuing her efforts to find Daniela by searching online and contacting
我一直都在梦到她。妈妈说她已经过世了，但她还是会经常来看我。”朱莉表示自己无法回答这个问题，但安慰科拉说无论如何他们都会继续寻找丹妮拉。尽管科拉似乎满足于理解妈妈不会回家的事实，但朱莉决心为这个小女孩讨回答案，好让她不用一辈子都在寻找真相。生活还在继续，朱莉通过在网上搜索和联系
media outlets, including Casefile. Daniela became involved in the story in December 2018 and had ongoing contact with several of Daniela's family members, friends and associates, who provided information that led to the creation of this episode. In the last week of April 2019, nine and a half months after Daniela went missing, an off-duty sergeant for the Mobile Police Department dive team was mapping out areas for training exercises at the Bayou-Sara River in Saraland, approximately 17 miles north of the Shell gas station where Daniela was last seen.
包括《罪案档案》（Casefile）在内的媒体，继续着她寻找丹妮拉的努力。《罪案档案》于2018年12月介入了这起报道，并与丹妮拉的多位家属、朋友和熟人保持着持续联系，他们提供了促成这一集节目制作的信息。2019年4月的最后一周，即丹妮拉失踪九个半月后，莫比尔警察局潜水队的一名休班中士正在萨拉兰德（Saraland）的拜尤萨拉河（Bayou-Sara River）规划训练演习区域，该河位于丹妮拉最后一次被目击的壳牌加油站以北约17英里处。
The Bayou-Sara is a long, wide and gentle stream that expands out from the Mobile River. The main access point to the river is via the Bayou-Sara boat launch, a public park in a quiet residential area that's popular with locals for fishing, boating, swimming and other water activities. The park is surrounded by tall trees, shrubbery and grass, with a long wooden footbridge extending along the banks of the water. Towards the drop-off of the Bayou-Sara public boat launch, where the water reached between 20 and 30 feet deep, the sergeant noticed something unusual.
拜尤萨拉河是一条长而宽阔且水流平缓的河流，从莫比尔河延伸开来。通往该河的主要通道是拜尤萨拉船只下水处（Bayou-Sara boat launch），这是位于一个安静住宅区内的公共公园，深受当地人喜爱，适合钓鱼、划船、游泳和其他水上活动。公园四周环绕着高大的树木、灌木丛和草地，一条长长的木质人行桥沿着水边延伸。在拜尤萨拉公共船只下水处的陡坡前——那里的水深在20到30英尺之间——这位中士注意到了一些不寻常的东西。
He marked the spot using a GPS, recognizing it as a training opportunity for the dive team to investigate further. On Thursday May 2, 2019, the sergeant returned to the area along with the dive team and additional equipment. They quickly identified the submerged item to be a vehicle and notified the police department that they had located what was most likely a stolen car. Upon further inspection, it was determined that the vehicle was a dark blue Chevy Cruze with pearl motors tags and that there were human remains inside.
他用GPS标记了这个地点，并认为这是一个供潜水队进一步调查的训练机会。2019年5月2日星期日（注：原文星期四），这位中士携潜水团队和额外设备返回了该地区。他们很快确认沉没的物体是一辆汽车，并通知警察局他们找到了极有可能是一辆失窃的汽车。经进一步检查，确认该车辆是一辆挂着珍珠汽车公司车牌的深蓝色雪佛兰科鲁兹，且车内有人类遗骸。
Due to the sensitive nature of the crime scene, the vehicle and body were left underwater as investigators consulted experts to determine the best plan of action to retrieve them while preserving evidence. In the meantime, the Mobile Police Department stated they would be treating the case as a homicide until an autopsy could confirm the certain. On Friday May 3, the vehicle was retrieved from the murky water and drained on site. There was damage to the front panels on both sides, but other than that, the vehicle was in relatively good condition.
由于犯罪现场情况敏感，在调查人员咨询专家以确定在保护证据的同时打捞它们的最佳方案期间，车辆和尸体被留在了水下。与此同时，莫比尔警察局表示，在法医鉴定能够百分之百确定之前，他们将把此案当作凶杀案处理。5月3日星期五，这辆车从浑浊的水中打捞上来，并在现场进行了排水。车身两侧的前挡板有损坏，但除此之外，车辆状况相对良好。
The car and remains were then transferred to a secure facility to be thoroughly examined. In a press conference, Mobile Police Chief Lawrence Batiste revealed that the vehicle belonged to Daniela Vianne, but that due to the level of decomposition, it could be weeks before the body was formally identified. He did confirm that the body belonged to an adult female that couldn't say how long the vehicle had been in the water or whether it had been pushed or driven in. When asked if the body was in the driver's seat, Chief Batiste said he couldn't confirm the exact position it was found in.
随后，汽车和遗骸被转移到一个安全的设施中进行彻底检查。在一次新闻发布会上，莫比尔警察局局长劳伦斯·巴蒂斯特（Lawrence Batiste）透露，这辆车属于丹妮拉·维安妮，但由于尸体腐烂程度严重，可能需要几周时间才能正式辨认出死者身份。他确实证实尸体属于一名成年女性，但无法说明车辆在水里泡了多久，也无法说明它是被推下去的还是自己开下去的。当被问及尸体是否在驾驶座上时，巴蒂斯特局长表示他无法确认被发现时的确切位置。
He added that given the amount of time the car had spent underwater, it was unlikely that investigators would be able to determine where the body was originally positioned when it entered the river. Investigators had scoured other bodies of water during previous searches for Daniela, but never in Saraland. Caseball spoke to Daniela's friend, Shana Hayden, who had been involved in the search from the outset. Shana said there was absolutely no reason for Daniela to be in the Saraland area, and
他补充说，鉴于汽车在水下呆了那么长时间，调查人员不太可能确定尸体刚入河时最初处于什么位置。在以往寻找丹妮拉的搜寻行动中，调查人员曾仔细搜查过其他水体，但从未在萨拉兰德搜寻过。《罪案档案》采访了丹妮拉的朋友沙娜·海登（Shana Hayden），她从一开始就参与了搜寻工作。沙娜表示，丹妮拉绝对没有任何理由去萨拉兰德地区，因此
she was therefore convinced foul play was involved. Shana said Daniela wouldn't have driven that far without her phone, as she wasn't familiar with the area. She believed someone had either driven Daniela's car out there, or rode in the vehicle with her. Another theory is that her car could have been towed to that location. When speaking to the press, Shana said, I don't think Daniela drove her car 20-some-odd miles north of Mobile and drove into a boat
她深信这里面涉及不法行为（谋杀）。沙娜说，在不熟悉该地区的情况下，丹妮拉不可能在没有手机的情况下开车开那么远。她相信要么是有人把丹妮拉的车开到了那里，要么是有人和她一起坐在车里。另一种理论是她的车可能被拖到了那个地方。沙娜在接受媒体采访时表示：“我不认为丹妮拉会把车开到莫比尔以北20多英里的地方，然后开进一个船只下水处。
launch. She loves Korra and never would have done that. It's not plausible. Even though it does bring some closure, it just kind of brings up this whole other box of what-ifs and hows and who's. We are content with knowing what has happened, and now we just need to find out who did it. It'll only be a matter of time before the truth does come out. A co-worker of Daniela's named Christy Meisner told the press that Daniela viewed the purchase
她深爱着科拉，绝对不会做那样的事。这根本说不通。尽管这确实带来了一些了结，但它也随之引发了一整箱充满‘如果’、‘怎么做’和‘是谁’的疑问。我们满足于知道了发生了什么，现在我们只需要找出是谁干的。真相大白只是时间问题。”丹妮拉的一位同事名叫克里斯蒂·梅斯纳（Christy Meisner），她对媒体说，丹妮拉将购买新车视作她新生活的开始，但“引用原话，它最终却成了一个诅咒，这让我们很多人都难以理解。
of her new car as the start of her new life, but that, quote, it wound up being a curse, which is really hard for a lot of us to wrap our brains around. The person who did this is not going to get away with it. We won't stop. Just as hard as we were searching for her, they will come down. It will happen. A resident of the Bayou-Sara area voiced her opinion to local news station NBC 15 that given the amount of boat traffic, fishing and swimming that occurred in the river,
做这件事的人绝对逃脱不了惩罚。我们不会罢休。就像我们当初拼命找她一样，他们终将受到制裁。这一天一定会到来。”拜尤萨拉地区的一位居民向当地新闻台NBC 15表达了她的看法：鉴于河里频繁的船只往来、钓鱼和游泳活动，
there was no way the vehicle had been there undetected for over nine months. She said that locals didn't notice anything out of the ordinary, and that no skid marks or tire tracks were ever reported on the boat ramp. On Sunday, May 5, Julie Dykes-Thomas told the press that although the family was still waiting for the results of DNA testing, she believed the body found in the car was Daniela. She stated, It's just a numbing realisation that she's really gone. That's what you've been working for for so long and striving for and begging for and praying for.
这辆车绝不可能在无人察觉的情况下在那里停放超过九个月。她表示，当地人没有注意到任何异常，而且船只下水坡道上也从未有过刹车痕迹或轮胎印的报告。5月5日星期日，朱莉·戴克斯-托马斯告诉媒体，尽管家人仍在等待DNA检测结果，但她相信车里发现的尸体就是丹妮拉。她表示：“这只是一种麻木的现实感，意识到她真的走了。这就是你长期以来一直为之努力、奋斗、恳求和祈祷的目标。
When you finally get that, it's not closure. On the evening of Friday, May 10, one week after the vehicle was found, a candlelit vigil was held at the Bayou-Sara boat launch for members of the community to lay flowers and pay their condolences to Daniela's friends and family. A friend told those gathered, Everyone here has prayed for this, and granted it's not the outcome that we wanted. It was our prayers and our pushing that got us here. Help us figure out what happened so we can get justice and she can rest peacefully.
当你最终得到这个结果时，它并不是一种释怀。”5月10日星期五傍晚，在汽车被找到一周后，人们在拜尤萨拉船只下水处举行了一场烛光守夜活动，社区成员纷纷前来献花，并向丹妮拉的朋友和家人致以哀悼。一位朋友对聚集的人群说：“这里的每个人都为此祈祷过，虽说这不是我们想要的结果。正是我们的祈祷和推动才让我们来到了这里。请帮我们弄清楚发生了什么，以便我们能伸张正义，让她得以安息。”
I don't think that her car, ending up 17 miles from the last place that she was seen, is an accident. You have to get in your car and either drive down the interstate or drive through town to a whole other town or suburb city of Mobile, and then go back through this winding neighbourhood, over-road tracks, making this curvy road that kind of goes back and forth and tucks into this neighbourhood. It's not an area that's just right off the road that you would absolutely drive into. You kind of have to know where you're going to get there. It's not a real publicized area that gets a lot of attention. A lot of people know about it, but it's just kind of one of those hidden spots tucked away because you grew up there or somebody
我不认为她的车最终停在距离她最后被目击地点17英里外是一场意外。你必须上车，要么开着车上州际公路，要么穿过城镇去往莫比尔的另一个城镇或郊区城市，然后穿过这个蜿蜒的居民区，越过铁道，拐上一条弯弯曲曲的、来回折返并深入这个居民区的路。这并不是那种就在公路旁、你会不小心开进去的地方。你必须得知道怎么走才能到那里。这不是一个备受关注、广为人知的地区。很多人知道这个地方，但它只那种因为你在那儿长大或者有人带你去过而被藏匿起来的隐蔽地点之一。
took you there or whatever. It's not a place that you just get in your car and accidentally drive to. It's just that night overall. I do think that it's possible that there was an accident that happened that night, but I don't think that her and her car ending up in the water miles from where she was last known to be was an accident. Also, I don't know if other people will really understand it, but Fairland here is one of those places that you don't drive through if you're messed up. You shouldn't drive when you're drunk, but you know how there are places that you just go to avoid if you're doing something wrong, whether you're drinking or whatever it may be. Fairland is kind of one of those places. They have that kind of police force that just doesn't
它绝对不是那种你随手上车就会不小心开到的地方。尤其是那天晚上的整体情况。我确实认为那天晚上可能发生了一场事故，但我认为她和她的车最终落入距离她最后已知地点数英里外的水中绝不是一场意外。另外，我不知道其他人是否真的能理解，但这里的费尔兰（Fairland）是那种如果你脑子不清醒就绝不会开车穿过的地方。你本就不该酒后驾车，但你知道总有些地方是你做错了事时会刻意避开的，不管你是在喝酒还是在干别的什么。费尔兰就是那种地方。他们那里的警局是那种根本不
really, it kind of takes no shit. That's kind of the other thing with us is for her not only to have driven from the shell to the launch, but to have driven through Fairland in the shape that we heard her in on the audio and not having a passive destruction or anything from A to B. I'm not saying it can't happen, but you'd think that something would have happened up until she'd side-flights a guardrail or a car or a mailbox or whatever drove through somebody's yard, especially on that road leading back to the launch because it literally is like a snake. I mean, you come off of 43, you go over some railroad tracks, it snakes to the right a little bit, it snakes to the left, you go straight for a minute, and then you snake back to the right through a
好糊弄、眼里揉不得沙子的类型。这就是我们心存疑虑的另一点：她不仅从壳牌加油站开车开到了下水处，而且在我们在音频中听到她那种状态下穿过了费尔兰，并且从A点到B点一路上竟然没有造成任何碰撞破坏。我不是说这不可能发生，但你总会觉得一路上会发生点什么，直到她擦撞到护栏、另一辆汽车、信箱或者随便什么东西，甚至直接冲进别人的院子里，特别是通往那个下水处的那条路上，因为它真的就像一条蛇一样弯弯曲曲。我的意思是，你从43号公路下来，开过一些铁道，它向右稍微弯一下，又向左弯一下，笔直开一会儿，然后又向右蛇形穿过一个
fork in the road that goes three different ways. You know what I mean? One of those is a dead end and the other two comes to a stop sign where then you have to take a left to go to the launch. So it's just a lot to it, more than just getting in your car and driving down the road. On May 14, Mobile Police confirmed the body belonged to 25-year-old Daniela Vayan and announced that the evidence indicated her death was the result of an accident. Their early investigation had revealed that certain manipulations to the inside of the vehicle indicated that Daniela had been alive when her car entered the river. The vehicle was in park, which they believed Daniela had done in a panic when her car hit the water.
三岔路口，通往三个不同的方向。你知道我的意思吗？其中一条是死胡同，另外两条通往一个停车标志，在那里你必须左转才能去下水处。所以这其中涉及很多环节，远不止是上车然后顺着路开下去那么简单。5月14日，莫比尔警方确认遗体属于25岁的丹妮拉·维扬（Daniela Vayan），并宣布证据表明她的死是一场意外。他们早期的调查显示，对车内某些装置的操作表明，当汽车冲入河中时，丹妮拉还活着。汽车处于停车档（P档），他们认为这是丹妮拉在汽车撞入水中的惊慌失措中挂入的。
Daniela's family were told that she was found in the driver's seat with no seatbelt on. According to sources, the keys were still in the ignition, but the car was not turned on. The emergency brake was set, all the doors were locked and the rear window on the driver's side was down about two inches. Buttons that enabled the driver to lower any one of the vehicle's four windows were located on the driver's side door with a button to unlock all the doors located in the center of the dashboard. This raised the question that if Daniela was in the driver's seat and conscious at the time her vehicle entered the water, why hadn't she attempted to unlock the doors or open her window?
丹妮拉的家属被告知，她被发现时坐在驾驶座上，没有系安全带。据消息人士称，钥匙仍插在点火开关中，但汽车并未发动。紧急刹车（手刹）被拉上了，所有的车门都锁着，驾驶座一侧的后车窗降下来大约两英寸。能够让驾驶员降下车辆四个车窗中任意一个的按钮位于驾驶座车门上，而一个可以解锁所有车门的按钮则位于中控台中央。这就引发了一个问题：如果丹妮拉在汽车入水时坐在驾驶座且保持清醒，为什么她没有试图解锁车门或打开车窗呢？
Preliminary autopsy results didn't reveal any trauma to her body, but given the level of decomposition and amount of time she had spent in the water, the official cause of death was unable to be determined. Similarly, the results of toxicology testing later came back inconclusive. Police Chief Lawrence Batiste told NBC 15, This is still an active investigation, but everything that we have found to this point indicates to us or appears to us to be an accidental incident. He clarified that the people of Mobile had nothing to worry about, and that the police, quote, are not looking for someone who is going around abducting women.
初步尸检结果显示她的身体没有任何外伤，但鉴于尸体腐烂程度以及她在水中呆的时间，官方无法确定死因。同样，随后的毒理学检测结果也没有得出确切结论。莫Mobile警察局局长劳伦斯·巴蒂斯特（Lawrence Batiste）对NBC 15表示：“这仍然是一项正在进行中的调查，但我们目前发现的一切都表明，或者在我们看来是一起意外事件。”他澄清说，莫Mobile的人民没什么好担心的，警方“并没有在寻找四处绑架女性的人”。
A statement released by Daniela's biological mother, Joy, said, Daniela's father and I still have hope in the homicide division due to the fact that they have not closed the case and it's still ongoing. Daniela's Chevy Cruze was later auctioned off, presumably by the relevant insurance company, and was shipped to the Ukraine to be used for parts. The auction notes mentioned that the vehicle had sustained flood damage and that it came without keys. Photos included with the auction documentation showed that the back passenger seat belt had been completely removed. Investigators have never made any mention of this.
丹妮拉（Daniela）的亲生母亲乔伊（Joy）发表了一份声明称：“丹妮拉的父亲和我对凶杀科仍然抱有希望，因为他们还没有结案，调查仍在继续。”丹妮拉的雪佛兰科鲁兹后来被拍卖，据推测是由相关保险公司处理的，并被运往乌克兰用于拆解零件。拍卖记录显示，该车曾遭受洪水浸泡且没有钥匙。拍卖文件附带的照片显示，后排乘客安全带已被完全拆除。调查人员从未提及过这一点。
The Mobile Police Department has been reluctant to publicly release any further details about Daniela's death. They have confirmed to the family that the investigation is open, but not being actively worked on. Many of Daniela's loved ones believe that her death was not an accident, as many unanswered questions and inconsistencies remain. In the months following the discovery of Daniela Vayan's body, those close to her distributed signs around Mobile demanding justice for Daniela. Around the start of 2020, several of the signs began disappearing. Julie and Shana continue to seek answers and hope that those who may know something of importance
莫Mobile警察局一直不愿公开透露有关丹妮拉死因的更多细节。他们向家属确认该案处于未结状态，但并未积极侦办。丹妮拉的许多亲友认为她的死并非意外，因为仍有许多未解之谜和矛盾之处。在丹妮拉·瓦扬（Daniela Vayan）的遗体被发现后的几个月里，与她亲近的人在莫Mobile各地散发标牌，要求为丹妮拉伸张正义。大约在2020年初，几个标牌开始消失。朱莉（Julie）和沙娜（Shana）继续寻找答案，并希望那些可能知道重要情况的人
will come forward. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
能够站出来。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。